Carlisle your clients your clients some
of them are Republicans some of them are
Democrats some of them are independent
some of them are you know politically
they're all over the place right you're
not going to just
maybe even more of your clients are
Republican than Democrats possibly I
don't know if they are or not but you
don't do a survey and say so who did you
vote for you can't do that it's not
something that you do but you know where
they lean it's like you know when
they're giving money to one Saturday
like do you know Schwartzman where he
leans you know where you know a uh JP
Morgan leans you know where Larry
finklings you know where a lot of these
guys lean it's not hard to kind of
figure out what these guys lean how do
you uh I run an insurance company we've
licensed nearly 40 000 people you know
we have I don't know 15 000 agents
Nationwide few hundred offices
Nationwide we just sold the company to
IMG
who the money came from Silver Lake you
know these companies you know these
names so you know but some of the guys
that you have they're Democrats some of
them are Republican and you know you're
you're spending your Thanksgiving I mean
president was with you during
Thanksgiving no let me be honest I lent
him the house I I wasn't there I wasn't
I was in Florida but even that like I
mean to say you know okay bite and stay
so if I go like and the only reason I'm
saying this this is actually a question
I'm asking because a lot of people are
uncomfortable about this so you know
where you know you ask Sam bankman freed
and he said yeah I don't know who I'm
going to give the money to I may get I'm
gonna probably give him the money to
both people on both both sides of the
aisle I'm going to give to some
Republicans some Democrats you know but
then some of the guys at the top you
notice they're typically on one side who
they're giving money to how do you
manage the relationships where they say
Let me let me describe yeah I'm curious
I worked in the white house for
President Carter
um we lost the election to Ronald Reagan
so an election uh changed my future I
thought I would stay in the White House
another four years I decided to get out
of politics and to do something
different with my life I don't give
money to any politician in zero I'm not
involved never none zero none what's
your philosophy for that I'm curious
well my view is I like to be friendly
with people in the Democratic party and
people in the Republican party and I
don't want people to judge me by who I
made a campaign contribution to and also
when you're giving gigantic sums of
people money to people you have to
wonder
um is that a really great thing for
democracy so I I I don't want to
criticize other people do it I I stay
out of that what I try to do is bring
people together in this way
um I host a lunch a dinner for members
of Congress only members of Congress
once a month I try to I bring in a great
historian and I will uh interview that
person in front of only members of
Congress I asked the Democrats
Republicans to sit with people from the
opposite party people from the opposite
house doing it for seven years and
people love it they say it's one of the
most interesting things they're doing in
Congress is going to this dinner because
there's no press there they can sit and
talk with people from the opposite party
which they rarely are allowed to do in
today's environment in Washington DC
um but if I was known as a big Democrat
or a big Republican it'd be harder to do
that I'm chairman of the Kennedy Center
I've been chairman for 13 years if I was
an active Democrat or actually act a
republican I think it'd be harder to do
what I do which to bring Democrats and
Republicans to the County Center the
same is true with the Smithsonian when I
was chair of the Smithsonian I didn't
want to be seen as an active Democrat or
active Republican some people are but I
just thought it was better for me to be
able to bring people together from both
sides so that's the way I'd look at it
David just out of curiosity because the
fact that you you've never given money
to well I didn't say never I did years
ago many more decades ago but not in
recent 25 years since you since you made
your money let's just say since you
really made the one you haven't given
money up do you think uh if you were in
charge of policies it would be better if
none of us could to find out who's the
real candidate versus you know
constantly going out to campaigning
because a lot of this is now about
campaigning who can raise the most money
can you know become president there's a
general rule of thumb the person who has
the most money will probably win an
election is a general rule yeah I'm not
always and so clearly uh if this was a
different country we would call it you
know uh legalized bribery you're
basically getting you know if somebody
gives you five million dollars or ten
million dollars what do you think that
person wants for that they want
something I don't know what it would be
and I'm saying it's necessarily illegal
we we've sanctioned it but somebody's
giving 5 10 15 20 million dollars they
want something and you have to wonder
whether that's a good thing now
unfortunately members of Congress spend
so much of their time raising money now
that they they they uh they can't spend
as much time as they want on the
legislative matters 40 of the time of
house members is often spent raising
money that's a lot and the reason is the
more money you raise the more likely
you're going to win and the and if you
have money left over you can keep it now
more or less for political purpose for
the rest of your life yeah I'm not I'm
not a fan of that because that's that's
uh you you owe too many favors you know
it's kind of like hey I owe a favor to
this guy to that guy said hey remember
that one time I gave you this it's like
you know you're in debt to the people
that are giving you money I don't know
if it makes the relationship more
straight up David be honest I mean look
I don't have a better system
um I don't know what but better
government we we can have and as
Churchill said uh democracy is the worst
form of government except all the others
so our government has lots of challenges
our political system has lots of
challenges but I'm not seeing people
leave in this country to go to another
political system we have 50 million
people in this country who are
immigrants 50 million people many of
them are citizens 50 million how many
people have leaving this country every
year to go elsewhere maybe a you know a
small percentage very very few people
leave yeah because the country's got all
its challenges but still the best
country in the in the world anything
would confuse though why do you think
we're confused where you know I turn on
the TV sometimes as a guy that was born
in Iran lived there 10 years I lived two
years in a refugee camp came to the
states and I hear so many people that
were born you're bitching about America
like how how did Americans not be proud
of being Americans like it became cool
for the last few years to hear people
bitching about the country that gave
them the life that they that he gave
them
well 50 million people wouldn't have
immigrated here if it was such a
terrible place I think um no other
country in the world's even close the
other the only other country even close
in terms of immigrants is Germany about
10 to 15 million people but people
aren't rushing to China people aren't
rushing to go to live in Russia the
Philippines people are rushing to live
here and obviously now people are coming
across the border illegally and that's
because they're so interested in coming
this country it's not because people
aren't leaving this country to rush to
Mexico right right that's right well
it's good to hear by the way how do you
think the president's doing I know
you've commented on Trump on his
policies economy in the past before how
do you think President Biden's doing
specifically economic policies well
obviously inflation got out of control
it wasn't transitory I think the Federal
Reserve Jay pal used to work at our firm
I I've known quite well
um I used to work at Carlow he worked at
Carlisle for seven or eight years
um he's uh done a very good job but the
biggest problem we had is that when
covet came we didn't know what to do
with it so uh the Trump Administration
the body admination put five trillion
dollars into the economy which had an
inflationary impact and the Federal
Reserve came interest rates at zero that
had inflationary impact we didn't
realize how serious it was going to be
but now we're playing catch up I think
the inflation is coming down the economy
is in reasonable shape and it's the
Biden I think he's done a pretty good
job given the circumstance he inherited
so what all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red are black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody saying future looks spread toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]